i just want to show you what's going on
here look at least
three dead bodies being taken away
within the last few minutes
we've only been here a few hours and
we've seen
what half a dozen people die in front of
us outside here
whilst they've been waiting to get
treatment we've spoken to people who are
absolutely distraught who are
begging for oxygen who are calling on
the government to help who are calling
on
anyone to help there's people lying out
here
in the open who are attached to oxygen
tanks
and they're the lucky ones to be honest
they are the lucky ones some of them
still waiting
one of the one man told me that his
brother waited for
six hours to get oxygen just on one of
these gurneys out
here he got oxygen and died within
minutes of receiving it it was just too
late it is an absolutely desperate
situation here
this is the casualty area this is just
the area
where people are trying to be admitted
into the hospital
which is already full to capacity one of
the people inside whose mother is being
treated
told us that there were seven oxygen
tanks
to 70 people so there's a general
feeling of
great desperation this man here who's
lying on the ground there
still gasping we spoke to him earlier
he's been waiting for at least
five hours to be admitted into casualty
where they will assess whether he can be
admitted
into the hospital let's have a chat to
one of the
relatives of the patients to show we
spoke to you earlier
about a very desperate situation in
there tell me who do you feel is to
blame for all of this
to blame actually it's
really very actually it's really very
easy to blame anyone
but if there is one primary source
of lack of mismanagement here that is
the delhi government the state
government because
these hospitals are the responsibility
of states
are the resources of states and whenever
a disaster comes
government should always support its
citizens but earlier you were telling me
you saw there was lots of blame at lots
of different people
you blamed the government you blamed the
people
you blame the lack of organization yeah
tell me tell me
who do you blame what are your thoughts
now you've got your mother in there
you've already got your father
who's ill no no no my father is not in
okay
right come tell me what's the situation
like in there tell me what your thoughts
are
the situation is not good it's worse
actually
but i would like to make it clear that
situation is going to be more worst
if the authorities and government do not
listen to us
the the state of the status of oxygen
is that oxygen is available for only the
patients who are inside
not for the patients who are coming new